i'd protect you from the sadness
in your eyes that's donnie wahlberg's
touching tribute to mom
alma just 12 days ago he announced she
passed away at 78
after a long battle with dementia donny
and i spoke this morning you know i've
been
kind of laying low a little bit um the
last couple weeks because i've been
going from work to
you know her bedside and stuff i got in
and jenny said i think you should watch
the e.t
tribute you did good alma rest in peace
that's what i said to her that was the
last thing i said to her she did good
she loved your show and when you said
those words it just
i lost it i'm losing it a little bit now
because that's that's it you know she
that's all she
wanted to know that she didn't like was
that she raised good kids and that she
did a good job
as a mom when you said those words it
just i mean jenny and i
just literally cried for a half an hour
that's my mom
you know that's who she really was can i
play something for you
i want to show you something of course
he said now the first thing i'm going to
do is buy you a house when i get rich
and i said okay dawn and he did it was
still
probably the biggest thrill i've had
[Music]
i really believe that my success was
the universe and god's way of paying her
back i was just
a vessel to to
reward her for all the good that she
brought into this world and
i think you showing me that piece just
reminded me of that
donnie is also grateful for the support
of his blue bloods tv family
including tom selleck i call him dad now
he calls me son i mean that's how we
talk to each other off camera oh yeah
first he used to kind of rumble at me
like
what's this this music guy is kind of
weird and then uh
now he calls me son and uh he'll come in
and give me a big hug and
you know you get a hug out for tom
selleck that's a big deal of course the
wahlbergs are known for their drive and
commitment to hard work
donnie's also proud of his other show he
hosts hln
serial killer series very scary people
season three premieres sunday
he said if these plates fall i will
hear it and i will kill you what is it
about
very scary people that that people love
so much
i think it's our our inability to
comprehend
what they could possibly be thinking we
want to somehow
gain some knowledge and understanding
into
um what makes them tick so we could be
probably less scared is jenny a true
crime fan does she watch um
because i love math singer and she loves
very scary people